have you been watching uh yeah i don't
think there's any questions so far
maybe there are others from the audience
okay perhaps we can we can you know
they'll get uh
folded into the panel then if they are
if there are questions
okay so let me let me go ahead and
introduce our panelists as
as um uh you know as the
videos end up so so we we have a very
distinguished panel uh
consisting of uh well bois barack is
already on the
on his videos already pinned uh he's
from harvard
and uh boss has done really uh fantastic
work in crypto to begin with and black
box
uh you know obfuscation and so on but
then
he's since worked on complexity theory
he's the author of a
famous book with sanjiv arora so about
killing
[Music]
you know dan actually works on
supposedly the applications of
crypto to security but but he's actually
done very foundational work in
cryptography
as well uh you know as a theorist so
including um you know
sort of introducing concepts such as
identity-based
encryption and multi-linear maps
we have daniele michiancio from
ucsd who is i think he's been working on
lattice problems
ever since his phd he worked on lattice
algorithms and
that is problems and the foundations of
lattice cryptography so it's very
appropriate for
today's panel and and then
michele mosca from who is at the
university of waterloo
institute for ikc the institute of
quantum
computation at waterloo
he's worked on extensively on quantum
algorithms and
and uh and on uh uh you know quantum
safe
uh cyber security he's he's actually
founded a
company called evolution queue which
which is which focuses on this
subject so it's really a great to have
all of you here in the panel
um so for for the purposes of the panel
let me
broaden the the scope a little bit uh
you know
so mark gave us a fantastic talk about
uh
about um how we we have to update
uh quantum security in a in a uh
you know post quantum security in a
quantum world but um
you know let's let's broaden the scope
also to include
uh you know just the prospects for post
quantum
uh cryptography you know in terms of uh
uh well uh
is the right time to switch standards
and and
uh you know how how uh how confident are
we that
uh that post quantum crypto systems are
going to be
secure uh and then also beyond that
you know if you look at lwe uh then
even in the process of defining lwe
you know i mean that that itself
resulted from
from looking at
quantum algorithms for for lattice
problems and
in the process it it triggered something
of a
cryptography through um you know
homomorphic encryption and
obfuscation and so on that were made
possible by this new primitive so
so i'll just ask the the panelists
to to speak for for a few minutes um
about whatever they wish to address
including
mark's talk as well as any of any other
any other issues on this subject so
you can go around starting with boys and
and
dan and then danielle and michael
sure so um yeah so thank you
mark for the talk and uh i do agree that
there is more to post quantum
cryptography than lattices but uh
lattices are right now i guess a major
uh and a
a major component of uh publicly crypto
based on
uh that is at least a plausibly secure
with respect to quantum adversaries
and yeah i think in terms of whether
uh post you know let's say lattice-based
crypto i
will be adopted as a standard i mean i
think there is
some sense in which
and maybe it's a good thing for crypto
that
the quantum computers are coming because
there is something very elegant about
uh lwe as a source for all uh
you know it has been shown to derive um
great many
crypto applications including several
that we don't know how to base in other
assumptions so in some sense
maybe you know if quantum computers
didn't exist we cryptographers would
have had to invent it so we would move
to this very nice
unified way so i don't see a
you know i mean i think factoring a
discrete log
based cryptography has a 30-year head
start so it has been
heavily optimized and then it's more
mature than
than a lattice-based crypto but
i you know maybe it's because i'm a
theorist but i don't see an
inherent obstacle as to why
these new standards wouldn't you
wouldn't switch to new standards and i
guess
it a little bit depends on whether the
application is for
signatures or for encryption if you are
trying to
use use cryptography for integrity then
you might not be worried
about whether a hypothetical machine is
going to be built
15 years from now because the intended
recipient is going to verify
your message today but if you're sending
out
something that is a secret and you think
it might still be a secret in 15 years
from now then you are worried about a
hypothetical
machine that would be built 15 years
from now and it could be the case that
just the prospect of a machine existing
is enough for
us to change to a whole new standard and
then maybe there is even no point in
building a machine anymore because
no one is using those cryptosystems
[Laughter]
thanks uh thanks for us uh yeah well
maybe there would be a point to building
the machine to
to decrypt all the messages that were
sitting there from
from now uh so
done okay um
so actually i want to make two points
but uh uh just to pause this point uh i
mean
you know uh building a quantum computer
just to break
uh crypto is not really a good
motivation to build a quantum computer
so hopefully there are other
applications outside of breaking or
breaking crypto and i think there are
like the chemistry and
and such so i wanted to make uh two
quick points
uh the first point i want to make
actually is
to say that we we kind of as the crypto
community
we are somewhat failing the
practitioners in in in the following
sense
um so there's a demand out there for
a post quantum signature that has both
short public keys and short signatures
when i say short public keys and short
signatures i mean as
short as in the pre-quantum world yeah
so today basically
if you look at signatures that are used
out there like schnoor signatures or bls
or
any of those uh the the public key and
the signature size
together are about 80 bytes yeah public
key
public key length plus signature size is
80 bytes
there's actually a great need for a post
quantum secure signature that is as
short
as 80 bytes and today we're no nowhere
near that
so in some sense we're kind of uh i have
to say that this is a problem that's
been bugging me for a long time i've
been trying to solve it
for a long time but everything every
candidate construction that i come up
come up with i'm also able to break
so it's been i'm kind of looking for
help
um and i say that uh by
us not providing this we're kind of not
you know not responding to the needs
of the of the of the community so that's
a challenge
could you say how far from 18 you are
now
okay well that depends on the
assumptions on which which assumption
you're willing to live with
i think in the in the kind of the regime
of assumptions that everybody is happy
with
we're in several in many hundreds of
bytes
yeah so we're part of kind of an order
of magnitude away from where where we'd
like to be
now i have to say that i was excited
about um
i saw gene-based crypto as a way to
build these short signatures
um in particular the uh
esogenies that come from suprasingular
curves
but i'm actually less optimistic now in
that they would give
short signatures but this is again it's
a really really excellent question
uh in trying to do it so that's that's
one thing i just i wanted to kind of
bring up this challenge and i hope that
people can jump on it and propose
propose something that's uh
that's as short as we need the other
thing i wanted to say is actually kind
of building on mark's talk
uh there's a story that i like to tell
that um
uh it's kind of cute i think so mark did
you mention max security for max in the
quantum i said no
no oh yeah so just it's a cute story
that uh i guess isn't a paper that
mark and i wrote many years ago which is
on the security of just card or wagon
max right so the cardo wagman mac is
like one of the classical
widely used macs in the real world and
i think it's kind of amazing that if you
allow the adversary
to issue kind of quantum message queries
to the to the to the max signer yeah so
the adversary submits the superposition
of messages
and he gets back a superposition of max
it's really kind of amazing
that the classic cargo wagon mac is
simply insecure in those settings
yeah it just breaks and the reason it
breaks i think is even more amazing
the reason it breaks is because
if you want to interpolate a line
classically
you sort of have to make two queries to
get two points on the line
but if you're allowed to make
superposition queries where you
give a superposition of x's and you get
a superposition of
y's where the y's are points on the line
amazingly it turns out only one query is
sufficient yeah you can interpolate a
line
using on only one query to an oracle
that that that has the lie in its head
it's kind of counterintuitive but you
know it's it's true
um and so that actually is enough to
break the cardo wagman mac
and as a result something else needs to
be done in the quantum settings
uh other than a quantum cardobag or mac
and it turns out the answer is
instead of using two-wise independence
for cardobago and mac you need four wise
independence
and then things become secure again but
it's kind of a
cute um really bizarre bizarre fact
about quantum oracles that you can
interpolate a line using one query
and its implication to uh to max i
should say that that's actually been
generalized quite a bit
in that if you have an oracle that will
let you evaluate
a polynomial degree d classically you
would need d
queries to interpolate the polynomial
and quantumly it turns out you only need
d over two queries
to interpolate the polynomial and that
has all sorts of implicit implications
to shamir secret sharing all of a sudden
you know with quantum
shameer secret chairs you can actually
break shameer secret sharing with fewer
shares
than you would uh you would classically
so i don't know there's like a
these quantum oracles are really quite
behave quite differently than how we
would intuitively think and it's really
kind of a fascinating area almost
independent of crypto but has lots of
implications to crypto as well so i'll
stop there thanks
okay thanks thanks dan that's great
um danielle yes okay
so uh well of course quantum
cryptography post quantum cryptography
is much more for
much more than just lattice cryptography
no doubt about that but i wanted to
bring the two
issues to the discussion one is that
so this is not the first time that
as we consider a more refined
and perhaps even more realistic a view
of what
reality the real world is we find out
that
there are issues that should be taken
into consideration
when evaluating the security of
cryptographic primitives
and one such setting
is for example when you consider
security against the side channel
attacks
for example time timing attacks to
cryptographic primitives
and it is clear that an adversary has
access to timing information or power
consumption information may get an edge
and these attacks have been exploited in
practice
so at the same time till today after
um 20 years of timing attacks and
side channel attacks so this is still
something that is considered
more of a specialized area and
much of the cryptography is done and
analyzed
assuming a computational model an
abstract computational model where the
adversary
does not have access to timing
information
and securing cryptographic functions
cryptographic primitives against the
site channel attacks
is considered also is still considered
very important
but it is somehow separated from
the part of the crypto design it's
considered
to some extent an implementation problem
and there are people specialize on how
to implement
giving cryptographic functions in a way
that is resistant
against channel attacks and there is a
all a host of techniques that can be
used in that setting
so the question is to what extent that
you may try to approach the problem of
quantum
security and conspantum security in a
similar way
and so that you can still design
cryptography um without quantum
knowledge and considerations and then
having the extra work
that comes up when you want to build and
deploy the functions
of course this requires
[Music]
interfaces that are classic to the
primitives
so you were drawing a distinction
between whether the proof
has one or another type of access to the
adversary so that's something that is
specific to the proof
it's kind of technical but something
that is
more general is whether
the user has access
so if the implementation is supposed to
provide
an interface to encrypt for example
superpositional messages
or it only provides the ability to
encrypt the classical messages
and you may consider the first one as a
new or extended cryptographic primitive
in some sense they have different
input output interface at the user level
so you may think of one
to be an extension of the other one now
if you settle for
a classical user interface where
the increase the messages being
encrypted are classical the cipher text
are classical and so on so this
something in principle one
could think of address at the
implementation level by specifying
that whenever you implement a
cryptographic function
you should do it in a way that the
encryption
hardware observes the message being
encrypted
so that it collapses to a classical
message and it just does not provide
the ability to uh compute
encryptions of the message
superpositions and you could do
something similar also for other
primitives
so i don't know how to what extent this
is something
feasible or something that would address
part of the concerns that you were
bringing up so the other issue that i
wanted to bring up is
okay so maybe it is interesting to look
at these enhanced cryptographic
primitives where you can
encrypt the quantum superposition of a
message
but rather than looking at it as a way
to protect the primitive against
adversaries that may do that
to try to trick the scheme into the
breaking
and being attacked so another question
that you may ask
is so are there uses for this are there
so we use encryptions to build also of
higher level protocols in
cryptography and so are there
other cryptographic applications
building
other more complex primitives where
you can make an interesting use of this
enhanced quantum fully quantum
encryption scheme
that allows to compute
the encryption of the quantum messages
now i don't know the area very well so i
don't know perhaps there is already some
work along these lines
but i wanted to ask you if there's
anything like this or if you see that
as an interesting possibility
as encryption of quantum messages being
used
to build richer
cryptographic applications so to make
use of it
to do something that otherwise would be
hard to do using a classic
encryption scheme which only offers the
ability to encrypt the classical
messages
great thanks thanks daniele yeah that's
a really good question but i i think we
should um
you know maybe uh michele yeah thanks
thanks everyone um i mean i think this
is a really exciting time to be a
cryptographer
uh usually um you know
when we show up with better cryptography
we're viewed as is people bringing a gun
to a knife fight
like just why are you here cryptography
is not the problem and i think
quantum maybe changes that mindset um
because it's a it's a concrete threat
it's not here yet fortunately but it's
not
a one percent chance that everything
systemic systemically collapses
it's an increasing acceleratingly
increasing chance that
we're gonna have the systemic threat so
suddenly we have a case
to be taken seriously and we can revamp
our cryptographic tools
um and approaches and practice and not
just you know
develop more theory that many of us
would like to see applied and it doesn't
get applied
and if we do it proactively we cannot
just be resilient against known quantum
threats
but we can do we can develop we can
deploy a lot of these better practices
we all know
and build more resilient systems that
are resilient to other threats both
known and unknown
so i hope we can change sort of the
mindset for not just
more secure systems and more resilient
systems
um so because
you know again in practice people look
at this as a risk management
uh problem and then you know do i really
need better crypto and
it's a hard enough sell like you know
you think the pandemic would change
would get us to appreciate that maybe we
should prepare for that one percent
chance
of something really systemic that's a
very short-lived window of awareness
we're going to go back to amnesia bias
in a couple years probably so i think we
have a very
special time to really bake in more
resilient practices
um and another thing i guess it's also
you know we're we're at a very special
time in the era of crypto and that
a lot of these tools beyond just
signatures and key agreement encryption
are actually getting taken seriously
maybe and that's wonderful
and we you know we want to support that
and make them either quantum resilient
or at least have a pathway
toward quantum resilience um so i guess
i just want to highlight
given this special era where we have a
special opportunity for a lot of these
great possibilities actually get
deployed in practice
a few things that might be nicer maybe
if we get better as a community and
offering a practitioner's guide
to the real world you know the
practitioners because it's hard to
decrypt what people are saying and if
you take things too literally they think
well this is weird
ivory tower stuff i don't need it's like
no you don't get it
so i think we have to explain why
approval security
you know how to interpret it and use it
how to make the right trade-offs like
you know if i'm going to absorb you know
dan talked about performance like
that's a real thing and it's a real
constraint
and if i'm going to go to for a given
size key is it better to have
a worse case to average case reduction
or more bits of security against known
attacks i don't know but i mean but
those are the kinds of trade-offs people
need
like there's an arch to it there's a
science part and there's an art part
uh another thing i find when i you know
work with clients and the you know
a lot of crypto can be replaced with
more trust assumptions
and i i'm not aware of a really simple
framework for
just talking about different kinds of
trust assumptions like
like a certificate authority is a
certain kind of trust assumption
you're not trusting secrecy it's a you
know short-term authenticity thing
so somehow framing the trust assumptions
so you can compare that then
and how do you trade them off against
cryptographic assumptions
another thing which you know i notice is
not
really if it exists it's not well
practiced
is how do we have formalisms that better
deal with degrading computational
assumptions
right quantum computer coming and
breaking our current tools is an example
of that
and when we tried to articulate
advantages of quantum cryptography for
example
we realized the language really wasn't
there and that's useful when you're
dealing with long-term confidentiality
or
long-term data integrity uh and lastly
can we turn you know as we go we go
after crypt you know we have one crypto
migration after another and we go
through the same pains
it's really becoming we need to get
better at this because the knife fight
already is a gun fight and it's going to
be a bazooka fight and a
worse soon so we have to get more you
know better all
building blocks for building secure
systems both the technology as well as
sort of the human practices
um so can we develop a more well-defined
science of cryptographic agility and
cryptographic migration
it's largely treated as an engineering
problem kind of like danielle was
talking about side channels yeah that's
the engineer's problem
well maybe there's something
cryptographers can do too
for example shai gueron did some nice
work and others on
like here's different ways to do hybrid
key agreement
and here's the pros and cons so um
there's probably some nice cryptographic
work to be done too
uh in terms of agility and migration
oh great thanks um so mark would you
would you like to respond to any
um sure i i guess i'll answer the
the question about um sort of positive
applications
of you know security against uh
superpositions and stuff like that
um and uh i guess one
one point is that if you're if you're
honest parties are running quantum
protocols
um they can actually they don't have to
run a classical protocol to encrypt you
know a quantum message or something like
that
and um and there there are
uh encryption schemes out there or
authentication schemes what have you for
um encrypting or authenticating quantum
states
um so so that doesn't mean that the
you know a classical protocol that
allows you to encrypt quantum states
isn't useless but you know maybe it has
sort of a narrower application
um and the other the other point is that
some things are just downright
impossible
um so for example signing a quantum
state
um in the sort of conventional notion of
what it means to sign a state
or to sign a message it is not possible
it turns out that
if you want to sign a
quantum message you actually have to
also encrypt it
um and so you you can't have a
a signature like what we you know what
we imagine where you can
you know look at the message there it is
and and tell
and then verify the signature so um so
it i don't know it's sort of a complex
picture i guess um
but but certainly um there have been
um classical protocols that have been
used
to build quantum protocols and in that
case you would
often need superposition resistance um
one example
is um these recent works
um building pseudorandom quantum states
so state the quantum states that look
like uh truly random states but have a
small amount of entropy
uh it turns out that these could be
constructed
from a suitable pseudorandom function
secure under quantum queries
um so even though the final protocol is
a quantum protocol the
underlying building blocks are are
classical so it is an important
um direction that people have considered
great um um i had a question so
um so you know you you uh
a classical cryptographer might hope
that um
you know that you'd identify the right
kinds of primitives for post-quantum
crypto you know
post-quantum encryption and a few other
protocols
and then life could could go back to
normal you know they wouldn't have to
watch their back every time they did
something to say well
do you have a new attack because because
everything is in superposition
so is there any prospect of that or is
it you know is our classical
cryptographers now
you know do they do they always have to
ask well
we designed this but now do you have
some crazy attack that's
that we wouldn't even think of
uh i mean so my my phd work was about
designing
uh classical crypto that uh remain
secure
against quantum attacks and um you know
we largely went through
the sort of the the standard
crypto objects that that people consider
and and either proved the existing
ones were secure against quantum attacks
or or gave new constructions
but the problem is when you whenever
like if you don't know how to prove the
original construction secure you provide
a new construction
probably it's going to be less efficient
and you know i guess there's a question
of uh
like is that trade-off worth it gift in
that you know
we don't know what uh we don't know if
these super position attacks will end up
being
uh relevant or not or to what extent
they will be relevant
so the question i think that often the
question we got was uh it's it's hard
enough to keep quantum state alive when
you want to keep it alive
so how how do you how are you expected
to keep it alive when you're trying to
prevent the adversary from issuing
quantum queries to you
um that was a i think this also goes
into what daniella was saying but
why don't we have i think we call this
uh classification
classic i don't know what the verb is so
make something classical right take
something quantum and make it classical
uh like you can imagine like a little
component at the end of every
every uh uh ethernet wire
that just classifies classifications
whatever whatever the verb is
uh the observation so that so that these
quantum attacks become become impossible
but um you know attackers are kind of
crafty right if you just have one
component that makes
sure that everything is classical
there's nothing to prevent the adversary
from just making their attack
by you know embedding a probe into your
machine
and just bypassing the classification uh
component
so now they're interacting again with a
quantum computer and that
brings up the quantum attacks again so
um i think like mark was saying it's
it's there's a often there's a
there's a cost to making things secure
against against these
quantum channel attacks but you know
if our whisper if our wrist watch is a
quantum computer
you know 100 years from now hopefully
our wrist watches will be quantum
computers
then maybe maybe not then it sounds like
that's a that's
a cost that's actually worth paying yeah
for
for this peace of mind can i ask a
question
oh yeah yeah so i thought i
took your question to mean something
else to mesh so in other words uh mark
you were saying that in your phd you
went through cryptographic primitives
and
tried to design them so they would be
secure also with respect to
quantum attacks but i think the question
was what's a quantum attack so as far as
i recall
uh like when you were talking about
surrounding functions you had a
particular
had to particularly define what the
quantum adversary could do which is
different than what the
what the classical adversary do and
prove that with respect to it
you know it was okay so that was your
choice and made sense
but uh i guess my question is every time
there's a new cryptographic primitive
new or old but uh then you have to
define to to use your judgment to say
what is the quantum atmosphere that
could do it'd be nice to be able to sort
of uh
that it wouldn't be up for debate it
would be clear what is the power of a
quantum
uh attacker and then you the problem is
to solve it and that to me at least as
an outsider
it does it is not clear because even
when we stand in front of the board as
all of a sudden mesh would say yeah but
the quantum guy can do this
he says oh so so it's like a work in
progress
rather than you know in the classical
cryptography we already have like this
real
even for a definition of security
there's a real versus ideal paradigm
it comes across in encryption and
digital signatures and protocols
in the quantum world i think there's
work to do there so we don't have to go
to a specialist and ask them each time
how would what is the quantum power here
so i wonder maybe there is a blanket uh
way to do it
yeah i mean i i think it's very unclear
right um
you know i i you know the example as the
examples in the talk show like some of
it depends on what your assumptions
about the real world are like is the is
the attacker going to be able to
influence your
um your messages in a quantum way
um and then also even in the the
security proofs like you know
there's you know basically for any
primitive there's probably a
straightforward generalization where you
just replace
probabilistic polynomial time with
quantum polynomial time
but um is that enough and it's not
always enough even for the security
proofs
um so so there's both like the sort of
modeling question
of what what we might think the
adversary is capable of doing but then
there's also just like how do we get the
the the proofs to work um and so i think
the question is
is very unclear and and that might just
be inherent
until we get i don't know some like
general lifting theorems that say that
you know any any classical proof of this
type gets lifted any classical proof
of this type you lift by tweaking it in
this way um
until we until we really have sort of a
really complete picture i i think our
definitions are going to sort of be
one-off like
you know every definition would have to
consider okay how is how is this object
used
um is it used in a way that the
classical definition can just be
sort of tweaked in the obvious way or is
it going to be used in
um some different way that requires
revisiting
the definition i think scott makes a
very good
point in the chat uh where he says you
know that they're
the attack surface even in for classical
uh
primitives there are many definitions
right so there is a
chosen plaintext ovens chosen ciphertext
and non-malleability and then there are
side channel attacks like daniella said
so
you might want to kind of separate out
there is this very base definition
which uh you know now called post
quantum
security where you say the attack
surface
and the interaction with the the the all
the communication is classical
all the attack surfaces as it was before
but the only thing that the
adversary can do is just run a run a
quantum computer computer in the
background to do computation
and even then we don't have as many
maybe as general lifting theorems as we
as we want to but at least we have some
of them and but
but then once you have uh once you allow
quantum channels maybe maybe daniella's
view is is the right way to view it is
just
to think of it as an extra side channel
a
a quantum site channel
so along the same line another dimension
to look
is yeah in the classical setting we also
have a standalone security concurrent
security different interaction models
and in fact i would argue that these
things are very important
whether or not you also bring the
quantum component into it
and having better ways to specify
what type of interaction an execution
model is being used
so having better ways to do that is
something that would be useful
in uh in general so then usually in
cryptography we said that oh and the
adversary can do
anything we want to leave it as open as
possible and
assuming the adversaries the power to
run quantum algorithms of course
is making a difference there
but the interaction of the of the
adversary
with the rest of the system is something
that even in the classical setting
is often a bit fuzzy and we don't have a
good
language to really describe that it very
easily gets
very very technical so it would be nice
if that if we had a better way to do
that
perhaps even from with quantum and
but that's something that requires
somehow to simplify the
language in which we describe if not the
proofs
at least the statements so is this
something
that you see as feasible with
with quantum
yeah i don't know i mean i i think all
the difficulties
that have been faced classically uh
everything just gets much harder
quantumly
um but uh you know we've we've been
uh i don't know i think we've been
making a lot of progress and sort of
um understanding quantum and anything
that we've done you know
anything we've done classically we'll
probably eventually figure it out in the
quantum setting but it'll
it'll take that much more time
[Music]
i'd like to ask a question if i may mesh
yeah sure
please i'm curious if there are things
mark you you gave a very nice example at
the end
about the silver lining and just now use
it everything yeah we do
um classically gets harder quantumly in
some way
are there more examples of things that
get easier when you go quantumly
and and more powerful i i've been very
inspired by scott's work on
differential privacy and connecting that
with his beautiful other protocols
um shouldn't it be possible to protect
and give
anonymity more easily quantum
mechanically somehow intuitively
anyone um i mean i'll give one example
um so the the the famous goldrich 11
theorem that shows that you can
extract a random bit from from an uh
computationally unpredictable source um
it uh you know it it quite complicated
the classical proof you know there's
this like random self-reduction and all
this
uh kind of stuff that you have to do to
get the the proof to go through
um and it turns out in the quantum
setting you can just make like a
you can make a single quantum query to
the the distinguisher and
and extract the value from it so so
there are cases where where things do
uh do get a lot easier with with quantum
but they they seem few and far between
yeah i think almost gave a really good
example in uh something that we can't do
classically but we can't do quantumly
which is verifiable randomness
right where you can actually tell right
uh
the participant is generating things at
random uh right
yeah i mean there's uh you know the
whole field of uh of quantum
cryptography concerns itself with things
that are um right classically impossible
but
um quantumly plausible um so we can
we can establish a a key over
over a a public channel where all we
need
uh information theoretically where all
we need is some sort of classical
authenticated channel this is something
we can't do
classically we need uh you know
computational assumptions but we can do
it information theoretically quantumly
um uh my favorite example is quantum
money you know how how do we
we can build currency that's um
unforgiable
um by the laws of physics as opposed to
you know the inability to reverse
engineer a piece of cloth
um or uncloneable programs or
or whatnot so there's sort of this whole
wide world of
um classically impossible things as well
that and i think we've really only
scratched the surface so far
great um
any other any other questions from the
audience
actually if i can make this one one
quick uh point
um i think often um people always
mention that like encryption is
something that needs to become post
quantum
soon because if in 50 years we get a
quantum computer then people can go back
and decrypt things they were encrypted
today
um what gets ignored is that there's a
real need to also move to post quantum
secure signatures
and the reason that's the case is um
that all of our software update
mechanisms depend on
signatures right if i can send i use to
send you a software update and you have
to verify that it's correct using a
signature
if we use a pre-quantum secure signature
and all of a sudden somebody builds a
quantum computer
then basically we're all dead right
because now all our machines will be
basically forced to upgrade to some
malware and they'll all accept it
because it'll be properly signed
yeah and so just for the purpose of
software update
it's really quite critical that we move
to uh
to a post quantum secure signature very
quickly
very soon hopefully just at the off case
as michelle says that uh
you know if it's built in the next 10
years we want to make sure that our
software update mechanisms
are secure so we can move to post
quantum secure encryption
yeah so between the two i think it's
actually really quite important to
quickly move to post quantum secure
signatures
to deploy post quantum secure signatures
unfortunately i don't see that being
done in the real world
so um that's that's something that i
think we need to
sort of push for more more uh violently
no well not violently more
aggressively that's what i wanted to say
uh yeah and i think that we also have
good solutions for this
in fact we don't need to depend on
anything fancy i think just standard
dumb hash based signatures are probably
sufficient for securing our software
update systems
and that unfortunately is not currently
a priority and you know i think it
should be
so i would echo that
and a lot of the theoretical a lot of
there's a lot of great work being done
like the nist process i think is a very
positive step
but there's a gap toward the adoption
and you know
when dan said we need to do quickly i
think he means as quickly as possible
and no
more quickly because if you do it too
quickly
now you don't need a quantum computer to
take advantage of you know to hack
systems because there'll be all these
implementation errors
and there'll be lots of losses as well
because things if you rush things are
going to break even without hackers
um they'll just crash or the
interoperability will be compromised so
um we don't want to wait till uh quantum
computers are
staring us in the face or until you know
a logic when a logical cubit is
demonstrated in the scalable system
uh we better be well on our way toward
uh this migration um otherwise we'll be
rushing
and then we'll make all sorts of
mistakes that will
again can be exploited without a quantum
computer yeah i mean
i i i sound that made that point before
i i
i think there is a sense in which we
have a little bit more of a rush with
encryption to something but but there is
another
sense which dances that in some sense
signatures are much more crucial to our
security infrastructures than
uh encryptions we could somehow
potentially imagine a world without a
encryption but not really a world
without signatures
and but but i i think there is also this
point of michael that we should not rush
the i think both cryptographers and
theorists in general
have a golden opportunity right now
to really kill our reputation by uh
encouraging you know selling selling
cryptosystems that we
hype as you know provably secure and
quantum secure but uh
ultimately you know basing on
assumptions that we don't have not
yet studied or using keys that are
shorter than what we should
and and we could you know if if some
if a scheme that is touted as quantum
secure
and provably secure gets deployed and
then gets broken that would be a real
loss in reputation and and basically a
real damage for uh
you know the belief involves what what's
your sense of hash based signatures for
this
no hash based like you mean basically
lampo type of things those are
yeah those those are uh those are solid
those have lots of you know history
behind them
and more talking about using very
aggressive parameters for lattices etc
that are
you know on the cusp of being uh
you know there is a difference i think
with choosing the smallest key
that you don't know is broken when it's
a problem with a
40-year history and the and when it's a
problem when it's a problem that was
introduced two years ago this particular
variant
but you're not going to get your 80 bits
with hash base signatures
you don't need to for software updates
it doesn't matter if the signature is
long
it's perfectly fine yes yeah i mean i
i yeah i love the hash but i had a paper
you know they're trying to get
black box low bounce for like the length
but yeah right
on the other end it's a little uncur
anachronistic
i guess just just think about it
encryption and
signatures i mean the truth is in my
opinion i mean we're past
it will not pass that quantum wise
although i do think that lampard and so
forth would satisfy it
but the the beauty of lattices is that
it gave you so much functionality that
we didn't have before
in homomorphic computation and so forth
and that's the beauty of it
so yes okay but you shouldn't be risky
with the keys because you because of
public opinion but in terms of research
that's where the wealth of that's where
the richness is that's where the beauty
is
so the idea of like emphasizing sort of
old classical
um primitives because it's practical
because the key size would be suitable
to applications for
sending messages and certifying updates
it's exciting for for industry i think
much less exciting in terms of
sort of pushing the limits of what we
can do yeah lwe is interesting
independent of quantum i think that's
that's the point you're trying to make
which is which is really important yeah
i mean
because we're getting things that are
just kind of unimaginable
and you know and if you wanted to
connect it to practice then cloud
computing or whatever there are plenty
of reasons to connect it
to practice so somehow
being conservative because we're afraid
that somebody's gonna find an
implementation
that has a short key you know okay
uh that's not what as a research
community i would
i would kind of advise
so are you suggesting it is time to
really push
on the fully homomorphic computation of
the quantum
algorithms no i i don't know about
quantum algorithms i don't know about
quantum computing anyway for doing
standard
computation but using quantum as a
capability
to do something extra that seems
extremely ex
fascinating i mean i think one of the
things you were saying about the side
channels was
as a way to use quantum maybe to fight
side channels
or at least this what i understood was
part of what you were saying uh
in terms of the measurement and
collapsing so that you cannot get more
uh or in general like uh the certifying
randomness or the idea of using key
exchange which is
perfect plus one way functions to get ot
those things to get more interesting
functionality using quantum
power to me that's what's exciting in
terms of research
but i know that's part of what we should
do is make sure that we're secure in the
next
10 20 years when the quantum computing
should come out
but unless so shafi are you it sounded
it sounded to me for a moment
that you were also saying that once you
throw it
you know this new stuff into the mix you
know like you're thinking about quantum
as well
then somehow it you you're forced to
look at look at
old problems you know and like with with
lwe um
you know even though the the push to it
came from looking at quantum algorithms
it revealed a lot about
clustering and so maybe there's more
such
things that can happen as we look from
from these new viewpoints
better i don't think the pushword came
from looking at quantum algorithms
as far as i remember the push for it
came from theory sort of the average
versus worst case
yeah yeah but we were lucky
right that so far you haven't been able
to solve lw in a quantum computer
uh maybe no so okay so
i maybe or that's here but i i thought
that uh
i thought that he was you know he was
trying to
get a give a quantum algorithm for
lattices and then
you know he had this uh the formula his
round trip
that you know in that quantum algorithm
and then
since that didn't you know since there
wasn't an algorithm there that was the
that was the hard piece that uh you know
i mean maybe your dad can say i think he
turned like a lemon into lemonade
you know it's basically the reason was i
i would have almost managed to get an
algorithm for lattices the quantum
algorithm for lattices but i only need
this i don't know what the history of
why he
brought it in uh
you know if he's he's still around
or maybe he's left yeah but
he he does say that it was an attempt to
add a quantum algorithm that had one
missing component to it
and that that was lwe
well great uh uh you know this was quite
fascinating and
you know thank you everybody you know
mark and
the panelists and the audience it's been
fantastic
um uh so we are
you know as always um uh we we can
we can continue the discussion on gather
town anybody who can join
um i put the link in the chat
and uh well for next week we'll go back
to doing the
doing the uh this quantum colloquium at
the usual time
11 a.m uh so uh and
it'll be john frasco uh uh
will be speaking okay so thank you and
see you maybe at
the capitol